sí
[Música]
cuántos de ustedes han usado la frase yo
me atrevo
muchos verdad cuántos han asumido un
reto y han logrado algo muy
significativo en sus vidas
yo quisiera compartir con ustedes
algunas de mis experiencias donde he
tenido que decir yo me atrevo
mientras estudiaba en la universidad al
mismo tiempo hacía cursos de alta
costura todo lo relacionado a las
manualidades me fascinaba era un mundo
que me gustaba muchísimo me gradué de
licenciada en educación
y conseguir trabajo de inmediato
ejercicio durante dos años mi profesión
tenía un trabajo bastante estable cómodo
tenía un sueldo seguro cobraban 15
último tenía horarios horarios cómodos
pero tenía una inquietud cuando estaba
en el salón de clases no veía la hora de
que tocaran el timbre y yo poder irme a
mi casa rapidísimo pero el tiempo se me
hacía muy lento mientras estaba en el
salón de clases
y porque quería llegar a mi casa porque
ahí me estaba esperando
una máquina de coser
ahí todo lo contrario a lo que me pasaba
en el salón de clases yo me sentaba en
frente de una máquina de coser y podía
estar horas y horas perdía la noción del
tiempo
realmente llegué
a convertir mi casa en un taller de
costura todo era un verdadero desastre
pasillos llenos de telas cuartos con
máquinas de coser
tijeras patrones retazos por todos lados
el polvo que votaban las telas todo era
un desastre y realmente yo todavía no
entiendo como mis padres aceptaron todo
eso y no me votaron de mi casa en ese
entonces
pero ahí descubrí que esa era mi pasión
que eso era lo que lo que me quitaba el
sueño y ahí tenía que escoger entre
seguir en la comodidad en la que yo
estaba viviendo con un sueldo seguro
comodidad tenía libre carnaval semana
santa
y vacaciones escolares y tenían que
decidir entre esa comodidad o asumir un
nuevo reto
me atreví desde atrás todo lo
relacionado a mi profesión y monté mi
empresa
para sorpresa de muchos y lo que muchos
no podían entender era porque me había
dedicado al diseño y confección de
trajes de baño
en valera zonas rodeadas de montañas
donde la playa más cercana queda a
kilómetros de distancia
pero
mi preocupación por innovar era tan
grande que me llevó a trabajar a
trabajar muy duro
quería crecer en lo que hacía porque
había seguido un sueño y quería crecer
en lo que estaba haciendo y mejorar cada
día se me presentaron muchísimas
oportunidades todas las aceptaba todas
las aprovechaba
llegué a canalizar mi creatividad
haciendo otras cosas
hacía trajes
de fantasía disfraces llegue a decorar
centros comerciales
todo lo que se me atravesaba que tenía
relación con creatividad ahí estaba yo
constante muy constante a pesar de
tantos obstáculos porque para comenzar
el haber montado una tienda de traje de
baño en una zona montañosa no era nada
fácil para todos era una idea
descabellada absurda quizás para mí era
un sueño y yo creía en él trabajé duro
y una de tantas oportunidades que se me
presento
fue la d
fallar en anime para una decoración de
centro comercial
decidí hacer un pesebre la idea fue mía
la idea maravillosa fue mía la gente me
preguntaba pero tú sabes tallar en anime
yo le decía no pero yo me atrevo la
primera oveja todos creían que era un
perro
pero eso no me desanimo seguía
intentando y llegué a tallar muchas
ovejas perfectas llegué a tallar un
camello de tamaño natural
tallaba mula buey las manos de los
personajes la virgen maría
san jose los pastores todo
yo misma me decía pero
yo no sé tallar
porque siento que sé pero era que me
estaba atreviendo a hacerlo y confiaban
lo que yo estaba haciendo y estaba
segura que lo iba a hacer bien
de esa manera
fui aprovechando todas las oportunidades
que se me presentaban
y una de ellas fue la de
participar en un concurso a nivel
nacional de diseñadores de moda
y una sentía que en el estado trujillo
mi trabajo era reconocido era valorado
pero ahora quería proyectar mi era a
nivel nacional quería que mi trabajo
hecho aquí en mi estado lo conocieran en
otras partes
ese concurso tenía algo muy particular
el primer requisito y el único era ser
diseñador de moda de profesión y yo no
lo era
yo me atreví
me fui con todo el positivismo del mundo
a participar
y aún sin ser diseñadora de moda de
profesión me permitieron participar
porque yo les mostré mi trayectoria lo
que había hecho aquí en en mi estado
y les puedo contar mi trabajo causó
impacto
impacto a un jurado conformado por los
mejores diseñadores de moda a nivel
nacional
pues carne el concurso quede entre los
seis mejores diseñadores de moda
talentos nuevos a nivel nacional
ahí cambió todo a partir de ese momento
comenzaron a invitarme a entrevistas en
programas de televisión nacional
entrevistas en radio
artículos de revistas pero para mí lo
más importante no era nada de eso sino
la forma como a mí me presentaba me
presentaban como la diseñadora de moda
trujillana
yo sentía que el objetivo que yo me
había trazado de darme a conocer a nivel
nacional lo había logrado
y además me gané un título ya era
diseñadora de moda
nadie me llamas nadie me decía profe
tanto que me gusta que me digan propia
por allá y está un ex alumno
atreverse a romper esquemas no es un
camino fácil de transitar cuando
queremos materializar una idea no es
nada fácil
considero que ha sido muy constante a
pesar de los obstáculos y he ido tras un
sueño
he trabajado muy duro muy duro para
lograr lo que tengo y me falta mucho por
recorrer todavía he creído siempre en mi
intuición
y eso me ha ayudado muchísimo
les puedo decir que la creatividad yo
creo que nací siendo creativa y la he
aplicado siempre a todo no crean que he
trabajado sola en todo esto no señor
siempre he tenido un grandísimo equipo
acompañándome
mi familia
y realmente considero que
eso es algo importantísimo
por eso yo les voy a decir
usen la frase yo me atrevo usen la para
lograr todo lo que se trazan en la vida
y verán que se llenarán de posts de
positivismo van a obtener el valor no sé
de dónde y lo van a lograr y la
satisfacción que les va a quedar a
ustedes es inmensa
yo sé yo estoy muy feliz con la decisión
que tome y nunca me arrepentí
hamas de la decisión tan grande de dejar
aparte toda una profesión para lo que
había estudiado por seguir lo que
comenzó como un joven mi sueño
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]